it's been a very busy month busy May for
Sorento you sold off rights to sin of
all that I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly to NAT farm for 1.3 billion
dollars this is a bio equivalent to
Abraxane a very promising new drug to
treat a number of cancers why do sell it
oh it's a duty to a good hens in the
express hands that developed the albumen
bound the paclitaxel which is a
blockbuster drugs and that we have the
collaboration unfortunately was the
experiencing team that knows how to
remove the drug of forward especially
established the effect see that there's
a that can be a beneficial for the
patient and their peers henry gia
morning if you could describe for us
what kind of work you're doing in the in
the area of breast cancer so the breast
cancer we have the chemotherapy that can
be useful and for treating the accounts
of breast cancer patient we also have
the emitter therapy the encoding the
immuno checkpoints that pd-1 PDL one
antibodies also you mean a cellular
therapy that we are focusing our effort
right now primarily as the Katya and the
car tank space which was up
collaborators conquest that we have off
the shelf in k92 cells that's very
powerful in killing that tumor cells dr.
G recipient in it dr. J I just want to
break in because people may not be
familiar with all of these terms are
just wondering if you can describe this
idea of an antibody library or antibody
platform and just take a maybe a 30,000
foot view so that we can understand it
yes so we're basically taking the human
lymphocytes and isolate the genes out of
the lymphocyte and using the molecular
biology our gene cloning to putting all
these antibody genes for humanty body
gene into a library that become the rich
sauce for discovery circulating
antibodies from the libraries we have
caught that Gmail
in a simple term that GMaps is such as
the Google Maps that you have a very
large collection we have the largest
collection of a human's their pinnacle
library everybody in the library and
that they have the best search engine as
well we are the bests winning and
technology for the G map technology dr.
G given the incredible run your stock
price has had a lot of eyeball a lot of
Browns have risen a lot of people are
suggesting you may be a takeover tark
talk takeover target I don't know what's
wrong this morning have you had any
talks with potential buyers are you
interested in selling that there is
always discussions that our company is
very undervalued at this moment because
we have the many assets mostly in the
Konica stage and in the preclinical
stage we have the most promise in that
platform him you know checkpoints
inhibitors in the antibody space as well
as the amino cellular space which is
such as Ducati and the car and K cells
which is an emergen a powerful play in
the car tank we call to market acting
new coupe last we with our conquest
partners we are very big into the car
tech space because the car tank is a
very powerful platform for immunotherapy
for cancer and some of the infectious
disease alright dr. Henry G thank you
very believable oh pardon we believe
that you know we are goes to make sure
that we increase the battery for the
shareholders before anybody is coming
over and the thickness of